New Claude Co-work update is insane.
Claude Co-work just dropped something
that changes everything. You can now
schedule Claude to do your work for you
automatically [music] on repeat. Morning
briefs, weekly reports, Friday
presentations, done without you touching
anything. This is not a small update.
This is AI actually running your
business in the background. And I'm
going to show you exactly how to use it
so your business grows while you sleep.
So, Anthropic just updated Claude
Co-work. And this one feature, schedule
tasks, is probably the most practical
thing they've released for business
owners in a long time. Here's what it
does. You tell Claude, "Do this task at
this time every week." And it just does
it. No reminders, no copy pasting, no
manual work. Claude runs the task
automatically on a schedule you set.
Think about what that actually means for
a second. Every Monday morning, Claude
writes a full business brief for your
team, pulling together everything you
need [music] to know to start the week.
Every Friday it builds a presentation
showing your results. Every week it
updates your [music] spreadsheets with
fresh data and analysis. That stuff used
to take hours. Now it takes zero minutes
from you. Hey, if we haven't met
already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO agency Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below. Let me show
you exactly what scheduled tasks look
like in practice using the AI profit
boardroom as a real example. Say you run
a community like the AI profit
boardroom. Every week you need to know
how many new members joined, what
content performed best, what questions
people are asking, and what you should
focus on this week. That's a ton of
manual work normally. With Claude Co's
scheduled tasks, you set it up once, you
write a task like this. Every Monday at
8 a.m., pull together a weekly growth
brief for the AI profit boardroom.
Include new member count, top performing
posts, most asked questions from the
community this week, and three
recommended focus areas for the week
ahead. Format it as a clean one-page
brief I can send to my team. You set the
schedule, you hit save, and from that
point on, every Monday morning, that
brief is sitting in your inbox ready to
go. You didn't do a thing. That is not a
small deal. That's hours of your life
back every single week. And before we go
deep on this, if you want to learn how
to automate tasks like this for your own
business, join the AI profit boardroom.
It's the best place to scale your
business, get more customers and save
hundreds of hours with AI automation
tools like Claude Co-work. Link is in
the description. Now, let's keep going.
Now, let me break down exactly what you
can use scheduled tasks for, because the
use cases go way beyond just weekly
briefs. First, daily morning briefs.
This is the one I'd set up first if I
were you. Every morning, Claude runs a
task that summarizes everything you need
to know for the day. For the AI profit
boardroom, you'd say something like,
"Every morning at 7 a.m., create a daily
brief for the AI profit boardroom.
Include any new AI tool announcements in
the last 24 hours, key metrics from the
community, and one suggested piece of
content to create today based on current
trends." You wake up, the brief is
there, you know exactly what to do.
you're ahead before most people have had
their coffee.
Second,
weekly spreadsheet updates.
Spreadsheets are one of those things
that everyone knows they should keep up
to date and almost nobody does
consistently. With scheduled tasks, you
hand that off to Claude. You set up a
task like every Sunday evening, update
the AI profit boardroom growth tracker
spreadsheet. Pull in new member numbers,
engagement stats, highlight anything
that's trending up or down by more than
10%. Claude runs it. The spreadsheet is
updated. You come in Monday with clean
current data. Third, Friday team
presentations. End of week reporting you
use to mean someone spending two hours
building a slide deck. Now you schedule
Claude to do it. Every Friday at 4 p.m.
build a weekly results presentation for
the AI profit boardroom team. include
growth stats for the week, top content,
community highlights, and three
priorities for next week. Make it clean,
visual, and ready to share. Done every
Friday. Automatic. Now, here's the thing
most people are going to miss about this
update. It's not just about saving time,
though. It absolutely does that. It's
about consistency. The number one reason
business reporting falls apart is
because it's manual. When things get
busy, the briefs stop. You know, the
spreadsheets go stale, the team
presentations don't happen, and then
you're flying blind. schedule tasks fix
that because the tasks run whether
you're busy or not, whether you
remembered or not, whether you had a
good week or a bad week, the business
keeps running. The reports keep coming.
You stay informed. That's huge.
Especially if you're scaling, especially
if you've got a team, especially if
you're trying to grow something like the
AI profit boardroom, and you need to
know what's working every single week.
Let me walk you through how to actually
set this up in co-work step by step.
Step one, open claude co-work. This is
Anthropic's desktop tool built
specifically for non-developers who want
to automate file and task management. If
you haven't downloaded it yet, go do
that first. It's a beta product right
now. Step two, create a new task. You'll
see the option to schedule it. Click
that. Step three, write your task. Be
specific. The more detail you give
Claude, the better the output. Tell it
what to do, what format you want, who
it's for, and any data sources it should
pull from. Step four, set your schedule.
daily, weekly, monthly, or based,
whatever makes sense. Pick the time,
pick the day, step five, save it. That's
it. Claude handles the rest. The whole
setup takes maybe 5 minutes and then it
runs forever. Here's where I want you to
think bigger for a second. Most people
when they hear AI automation, they think
of one-off tasks. Ask Claude a question,
get an answer. That's useful, but it's
not transformation. scheduled tasks are
transformation because now you're not
just using AI when you think to use it.
You're building AI into the operating
rhythm of your business. It's running in
the background is handling repeatable
work automatically. Is keeping your
systems updated so you can focus on the
high lever stuff for the AI profit
boardroom. That means I can spend my
time on strategy content and growing the
community instead of pulling reports and
building presentations. Claude handles
that layer. That's what I want you to
build toward a business where the
repetitive time consuming operational
tasks are handled automatically. So your
energy goes to the things only you can
do. Now let me give you a few more task
ideas that are specifically powerful if
you're running any kind of online
business or community. Content calendar
updates set Claude to pull trending AI
topics every Monday and suggest five
content ideas for the week. Relevant,
fresh, specific to your niche. No more
staring at a blank page. Community
health checks. Every week, Claude
reviews your community engagement, post
replies, questions, and gives you a
summary. Who's active? Who's gone quiet?
What topics are hot right now? You stay
close to your community without having
to read everything yourself.
Competitor monitoring.
Set a weekly task where Claude
summarizes new content, tools, or
announcements from key players in your
space. You stay informed. You spot gaps.
You find opportunities. Client or
customer check-in prompts. If you're
running an agency like Goldie Agency,
you can schedule Claude to generate
weekly client update summaries. What's
been done, what's next, what needs
attention, your team stays aligned,
clients stay informed. All of these can
be scheduled. All of them run
automatically. All of them save real
time every single week. One thing I want
to flag because I know some of you are
going to ask, is this safe? Is your data
secure? Anthropic has built Claude
Co-work as a tool for professionals and
they take data seriously. If you're
handling sensitive client data or
confidential business information,
always check Anthropic's current terms
and data policies before automating
anything sensitive. As with any AI tool,
be smart about what data you put in. For
general business operations, briefs,
presentations, content planning,
reporting. This is a powerful and
practical tool just like you'd use any
other business software. Let me bring
this together. Claude Co-work just added
scheduled tasks. That means Claude can
now complete recurring work at specific
times automatically on repeat. Morning
briefs, weekly spreadsheet updates,
Friday presentations. It's all possible.
Now for anyone running a business,
community, an agency, an online brand.
This is one of those updates that
actually changes how you operate. Not in
a hype way, in a real practical hours
back in your week way. The businesses
that win are the ones that build
systems. Schedule tasks in co-work is
one of the most successful ways I've
seen to start doing that with AI. Set up
one task this week, just one. See how it
works, then build from there. Now, if
you want to dive even deeper into AI
automation, I've got something special
for you. I run a community called the AI
profit boardroom. The best place to
scale your business, get more customers,
and save hundreds with AI automation.
Learn how to save time and automate your
business with AI tools like Claude
Co-work. And if you want the full
process, SOPs, and 100 plus AI use cases
like this one, join the AI success lab.
You'll get all the video notes from
there, plus access to our community of
45,000 members who are crushing it with
AI. The link is in the comments and
description.